digamos que tienes una bolsa y en esta
bolsa colocas 50 canicas de color rosa y
bueno obviamente no voy a dibujar las 50
canicas rosas pero escribamos por aquí
que tenemos 50 canicas rosas y en esta
misma bolsa colocas otras 50 canicas
pero de color azul
tenemos 50 canicas de color azul así es
que tienes una bolsa con 100 canicas
mitad rosas mitad azules y lo que vas a
hacer es cerrar los ojos y revolver muy
bien las canicas dentro de la bolsa
luego metes la mano a la bolsa todavía
con los ojos cerrados y escoges al azar
una de las 100 canicas y entonces te
preguntas cuál es la probabilidad de
tomar tomar una canica rosa entonces
teóricamente tenemos 100 posibles
resultados porque tenemos 100 canicas de
los cuales en 50 tomamos una canica rosa
así es que la probabilidad de tomar una
canica rosa calculando lo teóricamente
es un medio aunque aquí hicimos las
cuentas tenemos 100 canicas de las
cuales la mitad son rosas y entonces
tenemos una probabilidad teórica de un
medio de tomar una canica rosa pero
bueno digamos que realmente haces este
experimento realmente vas y tomas una
bolsa y la llenas con 50 canicas azules
y 50 canicas rosas cierras muy bien los
ojos metes la mano a la bolsa sacas una
canica te fijas de qué color es y
vuelves a regresar la canica la bolsa y
repites el experimento muchas veces ok
cada que metes la mano a la bolsa y
sacas una canica y te fijas de qué color
salió y la vuelves a meter a la bolsa a
todo ese proceso le vamos a llamar un
experimento
digamos que después de unos cuantos
experimentos por ejemplo digamos que
después de diez experimentos después de
diez experimentos
sacaste siete veces una canica rosa y
tres veces una canica azul
y será extraño que los primeros diez
experimentos no hayamos sacado la mitad
de las canicas rosas y la otra mitad
azules será extraño que hayamos sacado
siete canicas rosas y sólo tres canicas
azules pues no si la probabilidad de
sacar una canica rosa es de un medio y
hacemos diez experimentos
definitivamente es razonable que nos
hayan salido siete canicas rosas esto es
simplemente lo que escogieron tus dedos
al azar que sobre todo porque únicamente
estamos haciendo diez experimentos y
bueno más adelante lo vamos a definir en
estadística pero cuando tenemos poquitos
experimentos hay bastante varianza
entonces es perfectamente razonable que
de los diez experimentos en siete haya
salido una canica rosa así es que este
resultado no me preocuparía mucho no
provocaría que me preguntara si
bien las cosas aquí calculando la
probabilidad teórica pero digamos que
tienes muchísimo tiempo y entonces te
dedicas a hacer 10.000 de estos
experimentos
de 10.000 experimentos
aunque hay metes la mano a la bolsa
sacas una canica desde qué color es la
canica y las notas en algún lugar y
regresas la canica a la bolsa y vuelves
a revolver la bolsa y haces todo eso
10.000 veces y después de hacer todo eso
cuentas cuántas veces sacaste canicas
rosas y fueron siete mil veces aunque
hay siete mil veces sacaste una canica
rosa aunque sabes que mejor vamos a
cambiar un poquito los números vamos a
decir que sacaste ocho mil veces una
canica rosa
y dos mil veces sacaste una canica de
azul ahora esto ya está muy interesante
porque lo que estamos observando
experimentalmente no concuerda con lo
que habíamos calculado teóricamente y
ahora si tenemos un número razonable de
experimentos cuando teníamos únicamente
diez experimentos esto era completamente
razonable super normal que nos sucediera
esto sin embargo si hacemos 10.000
experimentos ahora sí ya esperaríamos
que si esta es la verdadera probabilidad
aquí hubiéramos obtenido un número mucho
más parecido a 5000 ahora si ésta fuera
realmente la probabilidad es cierto si
podría llegar a ocurrir que sacaremos
ocho mil veces una canica rosa sin
embargo la probabilidad de que eso
suceda es muy baja
ok porque son muchísimos experimentos a
diferencia de en este caso que son muy
poco
experimentos y por lo tanto tiene más
varianza ahora la probabilidad de
experimentar que obtenemos con estos
10.000 experimentos
la probabilidad experimental obtenida en
estos 10.000 experimentos es igual a ver
tenemos 10.000 experimentos en los
cuales 8000
8000 obtuvimos una canica rosa así es
que tenemos una probabilidad
experimental del 80 por ciento o también
lo podemos pensar como de 8 décimos lo
cual es una enorme diferencia con la
probabilidad teórica ahora yo confiaría
más en esta probabilidad experimental
porque hicimos muchísimos experimentos
aunque hicimos 10.000 experimentos si
ésta fuera la probabilidad verdadera
sería muy improbable que hubiéramos
sacado tantas veces las canicas rosas
entonces este es un momento en el que
uno se pone a pensar qué está pasando
aquí o por qué está pasando esto si
mezclamos la bolsa de canicas todas las
veces antes de sacar una canica si en
diez experimentos sale esto la verdad no
me preocuparía es completamente
razonable pero si después de 10.000
experimentos me queda una probabilidad
experimental
la probabilidad teórica ahí sí me
detendría a pensar en por qué está
sucediendo esto y bueno esto puede ser
algo por el estilo de que las canicas
azules pueden ser ligeramente más
pesadas que las canicas rosas entonces
cada que revolvemos la bolsa las canicas
azules están quedando más abajo que las
rosas y por lo tanto es más probable que
tomemos una canica rosa bueno hay
muchísimas posibilidades también podría
ser algo de la textura de las canicas
por ejemplo si las canicas rosas son más
rugosas que las azules o las azules se
resbalan en los dedos entonces también
es más probable tomar una canica rosa yo
no sé que esté pasando en esta bolsa de
canicas como había 50 canicas rosas y 50
canicas azules deduje que había una
probabilidad de un medio de sacar
cualquiera de las dos canicas
sin embargo experimentalmente estoy
observando que eso no es cierto estoy
observando
mil experimentos el 80% de las canicas
fueron rosas y 10.000 experimentos es un
número suficientemente grande como para
ser tomado en cuenta entonces dado este
porcentaje de canicas rosas sacadas
podemos empezar a pensar que tal vez la
probabilidad de sacar una canica rosa no
es un medio o que hay algo más en esta
bolsa que está afectando esas
probabilidades